People think they know my story,
but this is our story.
I just need a second, coach.
You're on the team here?
Nah, but I could be if you're lucky.
Me and my boys,
we were balling with each other
since we was like ten.
Call ourselves the "Fab Four."
That's going in!
Get up!
Hey! Hey!
We can win you a state championship.
Guaranteed.
When they were young,
I was just trying to find good kids
and they all kinda balanced each other out.
Willie.
Both his parents: addicts.
His big brother took him in,
saved his little brother's life.
Sian, we just wanted Sian
to work off a little bit of his baby fat.
Drew was born with
basketball in his blood.
I picked LeBron
because he had skills
and he was a good kid.
His mom just wants a spot
where he can be safe
and not get in any trouble.
Come on, pose Denzel!
We value all the talent
you boys are gonna bring to this school.
Oh my goodness!
Look at y'all!
And now tell me,
which one of y'all is supposed to be Carlton?
You? You?
Ma, stop!
They're not very good.
Now let's try this.
You're in the game, let's go.
We may be seeing the beginnings
of something special here in Akron.
Yo, watch out!
You watch out.
Maybe you'll see some new faces.
This is Mr. Travis.
Travis slams!
They're so damn good and they know it.
We in business!
Just make sure that doesn't tear them apart.
What's it like coaching
the best high school player in the country?
Play some defense.
Sorry, we can't all be the chosen one!
What'd you say to me?
How successful you become
depends on how well you
manage the pressure.
He's not just your player,
he's your son too.
So we just ain't gonna talk
to each other for the whole season?
What happens if nobody wants me?
You're a whole lot more than just basketball.
I wanted to make great players out of you.
Your dad wants to make great men.
That'll last a lot longer.
We here,
cause we know what we capable of.
When you look back at this time in your lives,
it won't be the stats.
It'll be that person next to you.
Did you make the time you had together count?
Right now I'm not thinking about the future.
I'm thinking about my brothers.